und dann muss man es auch noch selber am
zoll abholen also wirklich ganz
entspannt shoppen ohne irgendwelche
hintergedanken sollte man da vermeiden
etwas knapp und herzlich willkommen beim
ein video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht's gut
irgendwie bin ich ein bisschen dunkel
unterwegs heute und deswegen machen wir
ein 2
heute steht ein video an was jetzt nicht
unbedingt besonders unterhaltsam werden
soll
der sinn des videos ist ein anderer und
zwar sage ich mal so es liegt mir auf
dem herzen dass wenigstens einmal gesagt
zu haben weil man sagen muss ich habe
jetzt in letzter zeit drei mal halt
diese videos gemacht so dieser live.com
man als sachen relativ günstig bestellen
kann und jedes dieser videos hat
wirklich in ziemlich schnell derzeit
über eine halbe million klicks gemacht
das heißt dass haben ziemlich viele
leute gesehen wahrscheinlich auch sehr
viele etwas jüngere leute und wollen
jetzt wahrscheinlich viele zu den eltern
gegangen sind und gesagt haben ihr hobby
alexa hat bayerischen handy bestellt für
30 euro ich will auch ein neues handy ja
das ist vielleicht nicht so gut also ich
habe mich selber mal hingesetzt und habe
ein bisschen burschen genau ein
bildschirm
also ich hab selber mal interessiert ich
habe mich hingesetzt haben ein bisschen
zynisch recherchiert wie sieht das aus
wie sind da so die verhältnisse wie
funktioniert das ganze überhaupt wie
kommen diese billigen preise zustande
ich habe auch von einigen leuten von
euch fenster wenn wir da sofort sie mir
dann noch nicht voll gemacht dass man
schnell ist kurz die eigen ist die haben
mir geschrieben ließ jedoch vielleicht
mal diesen artikel sowie studie ich
bestellte besser nicht das ist nicht so
eine seriöse seite und so weiter und
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht wir machen
heute mal dieses video die wahrheit über
mich und ich möchte ein bisschen über
das er mit euch reden es gibt natürlich
vorteile die seite mit sich bringt
allerdings sind die auch fragwürdig und
es gibt eine menge nachteile wir schauen
uns gleich mal ein paar sachen zusammen
an
allerdings sollte ich wollen auch sagen
ich bin ja youtuber und ich würde
niemals jetzt privat auf die idee kommt
du kaufst du jetzt mal eine neue smart
watch the witch auch wenn ich wirklich
extrem überrascht war dass dies teil
funktioniert für 15 euro das du was
möglich ist dass die technik das
ermöglicht anscheinend ich habe
daraufhin nur gesagt ja wenn ihr euch
nicht sicher seid ist eine smart watch
hilfreich muss man jetzt nicht sofort
350 euro ausgeben um sich eine coole zu
holen hier in deutschland sondern könnte
vielleicht auch mal so eine ausprobieren
so also das sollte auf jeden fall gesagt
sein sollte
auf keinen fall zu euren eltern gehen
und sagen ja mama ich möchte bei
richards mir neues handy kaufen weil das
lohnt sich nicht dann gebt ihr 50 euro
aus denke ich mal das handy was ich
bestellt habe darüber
das kommt jetzt irgendwie nächste woche
glaube ich an also ja genau nichts woche
aber das ist sicherlich keine gute
qualität und auch kein gutes handy da
solltet ihr lieber die 50 euro in die
hand nehmen und warten bis sie
vielleicht 200 euro habt und euch dann
im handy hier in deutschland kaufen
womit ihr wirklich auf dauer zufrieden
sein ich persönlich kaufe das ja nur
weil ich einmal dieses video darüber
mache dies zufällig bestellen und es
dann halt auch noch ausprobieren also es
hat keinen zweck für youtube ersol
unterhaltung seien nicht selber kaufen
weil natürlich ist ja dieser gedanke da
auch bei mir dass man wenigstens noch
wissen möchte funktioniert so passt oder
nicht ich habe es jetzt im letzten video
wo ich die sachen ausgepackt habe schon
mal gezeigt dass es möglich ist und dass
die teile gar nicht mal so schlecht sind
so willkommen jetzt aber erst mal zu
einem artikel der mir oft geschickt
wurde so und zwar ist das der artikel
ist auf chip.de könnt ihr wahrscheinlich
die seite und die haben sich auch mal
bestimmt speziell wegen im youtube alles
sehr viele videos zu dem thema gibt wo
halt solche sachen bestellen ja mal
hingesetzt und haben einen artikel
darüber geschrieben den ich auf den
ersten blick gar nicht mal so schlecht
findet unter das thema eigentlich
ziemlich gut behandelt also wir haben ja
online shopping wird der workshop ist
das serie in der wirtschaft finden sich
vermeintliche schnäppchen zu sehr
günstigen preisen technik mode und mehr
für wenig euro
mode habe ich jetzt noch nicht wirklich
bestellt aber technik hat schon eine uhr
war zwar jetzt keine hightech uhr aber
ich haben sich auch technik und eine
smart watch also eine schöne goldene
rufen 15 euro und smartbooks glaube ich
für 18 euro oder so habe ich ja schon
bestellt wie gesagt das handy kann ich
euch mal kurz zeigen was jetzt noch
ankommen sollte das kommt bis zum 24
ich hoffe mal dass es schon er ankommt
und dass wir das dann zusammen auspacken
können da bin ich wirklich gespannt
drauf möchtest aber lediglich eine
plattform auf der online shops aus aller
welt ihre produkte verkaufen die meisten
anbieter komma china so das war der
erste punkt viele verbinden glaube ich
mit dem namen das ist so ein riesen
anbieter der alle möglichen schrott
sachen für wenig geld produziert und
jemanden kaufen kann ist es nicht das
ist ähnlich wie ebay oder auch amazon
auch wenn amazon denke ich mal einige
produkte mehr im sortiment hat alles was
es ist halt einfach eine vertriebsseite
vor allem möglichen händler
so könnt ihr auch persönlich als
privatperson ich könnte auch ein paar
produkte hochladen
man muss sich da jetzt anmelden für uns
weiter das kann man hier sieht
den verkauf über ruhig für händler der
schnellste weg um ihre artikel zu
verkaufen kostenlos testen blablabla
genau also da kann sich halt jeder auto
anmelden
die qualität der günstigen produkte
lässt mitunter zu wünschen übrig die
versandzeit von ca 30 tagen ebenso hier
muss ich jetzt erst mal sagen dass sich
ein bisschen anders die produkte sind
jetzt nicht kompletter schrott das preis
leistungsverhältnis ist finde ich echt
gut ich weiß natürlich nicht wie lange
sich so eine sache halten würde kirmes
wahre held drei tage sagt man ja mal
ganz gerne ja eine smarte 18 euro die
und auch funktioniert war für mich sehr
überraschend lieferzeit von circa 30
tagen stimmt auch nicht immer bei mir
kamen die sachen schon nach sechs tagen
an also zwei sachen davon die anderen
aber wirklich hat ist heute nach 30
tagen also die commerce mitte april an
waren sich dann auch bestellt habe diese
hose und so da war ich aber noch gar
nicht ob ich da wirklich ein video zu
machen werden wir sehen die bezahlung
läuft unter anderem über
sofortüberweisung und kleine abplanalp
einfach einen käuferschutz portal auch
wenn es sich hierbei um seriöse
zahlungsdienstleister handel raten wir
ihnen von dem kauf über die web ab denn
eine wirklich garantie auf lieferungen
qualität gibt es nicht eigentlich macht
die aussage keinen sinn ich meine man es
erst einmal abgesichert über diesen
kleiner käuferschutz dann besteht ganz
kleinen kauf verhältnis jemand bietet
sein produkt an
er bekommt geld dafür leute kaufen das
und dann ist ja auch verpflichtet das zu
verschicken wird das nicht machen kann
man dagegen vorgehen so also die
garantie sollte schon bestehen ich bin
auch der festen überzeugung dass sich
alle produkte irgendwann mal bekommen
werde zwar jetzt nicht unbedingt
innerhalb von der woche aber halt
innerhalb von 30 tagen was sie beim
shopping mit der musik beachten sollte
online shopping ist bequem wirkt
allerdings auch gefahren
dies gilt vor allem für anbieter aus dem
ausland bestellen sie mehrere artikel
können schnell hohe versandkosten auf
sie zukommen da wo ich lediglich ein
vermittler ist berechnet jeder shop auf
der plattform seine versandkosten
gesondert der das ist ein bisschen
anders als bei amazon also amazon
bündelt das nicht und sobald man
irgendwie bei 15 euro ist der versand
kostenlos oder so bayerisch ich habe es
ja letztens mal gehabt ich habe glaube
ich mal für keine ahnung was das war 70
euro bestellt oder 80 euro und war dann
aber insgesamt bei 140 euro einfach weil
der versand so brutal hoch war ist aber
an sich auch verständlich ich meine das
zeug kommt nicht aus deutschland kommt
vermutlich alles aus china da ist der
weg ziemlich lang mit dem flugzeug und
irgendwie muss ich das ja rechnen genau
jetzt im nächsten punkt da geht es dann
allerdings
um zollgebühren das heißt wenn ihr jetzt
irgendwie sachen bestellt im wert von
200 euro
kann es sein dass der zeuge noch mal auf
euch zukommen und sagt es ist viel zu
hoch ihr müsst noch mal drauf zahlen und
dann muss man es auch noch selber
abholen also wirklich ganz entspannt
shoppen ohne irgendwelche hintergedanken
sollte man da vermeiden haben sie
dennoch etwas bestellt ist geduld und
optimismus gefragt mit klarer müssen sie
zwar erst nach 14 tagen bezahlen das
wollte ich auch mal kurz zeigen und zwar
ich würde sagen wir tun jetzt einfach
mal dieses produkt hier in den
einkaufswagen ich wollte nämlich auch
ursprünglich mal so bezahlen und ich
zeige euch mal kurz für den
einkaufswagen wir gehen dann einfach mal
zur kasse und jetzt kann man hier
einfach erst in 14 tagen bezahlen also
einfach in die ware angekommen ist ganz
entspannt bezahlen
das sollte ich machen geht allerdings
bei mir wenn ich jetzt auf jetzt kaufen
drücke kommt irgendwie ein fehler oder
so ein fehler ist aufgetreten leider
konnte planer ihren kauf nicht
freigegeben hätte mich auch gewundert
bei den meisten online shops mit sitz in
deutschland und europa ist eine
reklamation eine rückstellung oder ein
umtausch kein problem sind sie mit einer
lieferung nicht zufrieden kontaktieren
sie jedoch nicht den eigentlichen
verkäufer alle probleme werden über ein
formular den kundenservice von mischa
dressiert so da denke ich mir auch das
könnte probleme geben erst mal noch mal
die erinnerung an alle von euch bestellt
am besten nicht über ruhiggestellt
meinetwegen irgendwie ein
geburtstagsgeschenk irgendeinen witz
geschenkt oder sowas eigentlich im
endeffekt keinen interessiert ob es
jetzt funktioniert oder nicht das könnt
ihr gerne über ruhig bestellen aber ein
handy oder eines smart watch auf
kleinsten weil wenn das kaputtgeht und
wirklich aus china kommen und ihr ich
denke wir müssen das jetzt zurück sind
also wenn man mal kurz nachdenken der
reklamation zurück nach china mit
bearbeitung und wieder zurück sind
da hätte ich absolut kein bock drauf und
hab das wirklich funktioniert das weiß
ich auch nicht mobiles online shopping
über einen app kann spaß machen
allerdings sollten sie sich die app ein
wenig genauer anschauen die web alles
klar hat berechtigung die sie eigentlich
fürs online-shopping nicht braucht ich
habe die app gar nicht die braucht man
auch eigentlich nicht ich finde am pc
ist alles viel entspannter
die apa zugriff auf ihre kontakte und
kann sie auslesen zudem erlauben sie die
anwendung mit der installation
usb-speichern leute zu lesen zu ändern
oder gar zu löschen
die app kann auch gar nicht nur daten
aus dem internet abrufen der zugriff auf
alle netzwerk und netzwerkverbindungen
zu guter letzt erlauben sie der richter
bilder und videos aufzunehmen wo hat
das wie das jetzt genau gemeint ist weiß
ich nicht ich kann mir jetzt nicht
vorstellen dass es irgendwie möglich ist
mit deutschem gesetz ist zwar kurz das
fazit wenn ihnen die qualität der
billigprodukte egal ist und sie einen
verlust von wenigen euros für mode und
gadgets in kauf nehmen wollen können die
zurückgreifen so also eigentlich genauso
wie ich gesagt habe wenn man youtube
video dazu machen möchte oder so gerne
kann man es ausprobieren wenn man sich
davon jetzt aber ein cooles handy
erwischt dann lass die finger davon
seien sie sich aber bewusst dass es
keine garantie auf lieferung qualität
und weiter verwendung ihrer daten gibt
ja das mit qualität auf kleinsten
garantie auf lieferungen ist auf jeden
fall da das kann ja nicht sein so dass
man nicht irgendwas bezahlt was man da
nicht bekommt man hat ja den beleg dazu
natürlich kann es bestimmt sein dass man
das ein oder andere produkt sagen wir
ein produkt von 100 nicht ankommt das
ist aber überall das risiko muss man
halt einfach reklamieren
genauso leute also an dieser stelle
nochmal vor allem für die jüngeren geht
nicht zu ihren eltern und sagt mama
können wir nicht mal zusammen auf wunsch
einkaufen lassen die finger davon es
gibt ja eine menge youtube videos dazu
wenn euch das ganze so brennan
interessiert schaut euch einfach die an
aber gebt dafür für den privaten
gebrauch wenn ihr irgendwas technisches
modisches kaufen wollt wirklich kein
geld aus meiner meinung nach lohnt sich
das nur recht selten ist natürlich
trotzdem eure entscheidung wir sehen uns
morgen wieder wollen gibt es ein neues
video ich hoffe dieses video
durchgefallen check zinslast nach oben
da wir sehen uns hart rein